we start with breaking news from Ukraine
where they've been new airstrikes on the
capital key for the second straight day
Ukrainian officials say three strikes
have hit a power facility in zetomir
let's get the latest from Mohammed
jamjun who's our correspondent in
Ukraine's Capital tell us about what's
happening today Muhammad
well Folly first I should mention that
the city and the region in fact the
entire country is still under an active
air alert at this moment there was one
that went off around 5 30 this morning
that's when the air raid sirens first
rang out here in Cave City uh then that
air alert was deactivated and then about
an hour and a half later there was a
second one and we are still technically
under that air alert and have not been
given the all clear that all being said
here in central Kiev it is relatively
calm we've not heard any explosions but
as you mentioned there were three
missiles that did strike the destiny
District that is on the Left Bank of the
danipro river uh just the east of the
capital now according to Keith Mayer of
Italy Klitschko there were energy
infrastructure objects uh power plants
we believe that were struck in
destinyansky District
um and because of that there are
concerns right now from local officials
being expressed that there could be
power outages that we would be
experiencing throughout the day in the
Kiev region and in fact in Kiev city as
well I should also tell you that there
have been other missile strikes reported
by other local officials in other parts
of the country including in which is a
neighboring City to Kiev it's in retro
the district the mayor of dretamir said
that that city was left without
electricity and water after critical
infrastructure objects and sites in that
city were also hit by missiles and also
in the overnight hours mikolayev was
bombarded according to officials by
s-300 missiles the city of danipro was
also shaken by missile strikes and other
parts of the country have been struck by
missiles in the last few hours as well
as I said Foley here in the center of
Kiev it is relatively calm it seems as
though life is pretty much going on as
it normally would yes the air alert is
still active people have been urged to
stay in shelters but people are trying
to get out and about as much as possible
that all being said it is a very fragile
Atmos sphere here the last few days
everybody that we speak with says you
know they want to make sure that they
are as close as possible to a shelter as
they can be in the event that those Air
Raid Sirens go off and in the event that
there are more drones that are striking
the city or more missiles targeting the
city thank you for that update live
there with the latest from Kiev